thanks so I will be talking about a
different perspective about subm modular
functions but talk about optimization of
them um so this is Joint work with uh
Andre grower and Ain sford both from Sor
University and both are in the
audience all right so um let's start
with some modular functions can't
briefly talk about them let me recall uh
remind you what they are so we are given
a ground set of n
elements and sub module functions are
set function
this means that they are defined on
subsets of the ground set for Simplicity
I will always assume that they take
integer
values right so sub modular functions
are set functions that satisfy the
so-called diminishing marginal gains
property what this means is that for any
two subsets s and t where s is a subset
of T and any other Element e outside of
the bigger set T if you consider adding
The Element e to these two sets then the
function value increase when you add e
to the smaller set s is at least the
to the bigger set t Okay uh this is sort
of a very natural intuitive property
roughly says like the the fewer things
you start with you will be happier in
getting something extra okay this is
defining property of a subm modular
function all right so um sub modular
functions are actually ubiquitous in in
applications a standard examples include
the utility functions uh graph cut
functions matroid rank functions which
we just saw from Ken's talk and many
others they're important modeling Tools
in many different areas um and
optimization of these functions have
also been extensively
studied there are a few very standard
textbook on this topic if you're
interested so this talk will I'll focus
on minimization of subm modular
functions so I will consider the
standard model where we are given a
submodular function f access through
what is called an evaluation Oracle so
you query the evalu Oracle with a set s
it will tell you the function value on
that
set we assume the range of the function
f is from minus M to M where m is some
big
integer so our goal is to find a
minimizer for the subm modular
function right so algorithms for this
problem usually consists the runtime of
algorithms for sfm consists of two parts
a number of queries to the evaluation
Oracle this is also called query
complexity of the algorithm and some
additional
computations so one of the most seminal
results on subm modular function
minimization obtained by grolo vas and
Shriver in a sequence of papers in the
1980s is that this problem can be solved
in weakly and strongly polinomial time
so here we see an algorithm runs in
weekly polinomial time for this problem
if it's query complexity and additional
computation is polom In N and log of the
range
M and with an algorithm runs in strongly
polinomial time if it's query and
computation is polinomial only in the
dimension n and in particular this
bounch will be independent of the range
M okay so since graas and Sher seminal
work there have been significant efforts
in designing faster algor weakly and
strongly polinomial time algorithms for
sub modular function minimiz
so this is motivated not just not only
by the fact that sfm is a sort of
natural problem with applications this
is also one typical example where
discrete and continuous optimization
meet and this problem itself has been a
test bad for new algorithmic techniques
in both these
domains in this talk I will focus
primarily on the query complexity aspect
of algorithms this is a more structured
compet structured quantity which you can
hope to prove non-trivial lower bounds
okay so what are the state-of-the-art
algorithms for sfn the state-ofthe-art
weekly polinomial time algorithms
algorithm has the query complexity
roughly n Square log of n this is first
given by leer one in 2015 and the
slightly improved in terms of log
factors by uh in a joint work with Le
and in
2020 for strongly polinomial time
algorithms the best query complex is
roughly ncbe right so I listed the four
papers here Le one the Z belly one of my
papers and recent paper with Lee and
John these papers all achieve roughly
ncbe career complexity they have a
slightly different trade-off in terms of
per complexity and the and additional
computation which we will not really
care about in this
talk right so if you allow a additional
computation to be exponential time then
the algorithm in my paper could actually
give n Square query
complexity so you see that there's now
this uh fact factor of end gap between
what you can do with strongly polinomial
time versus exponential
time so sort of if you're interested
this Gap comes from the trade-off
between approximation factor and runtime
for for uh approximately solving the
shortest Vector problem in latices which
I'm not going to get
into okay so what about uh right so
despite some efforts in trying to close
this Gap currently it seems that getting
a strongly polyal time algorithm with
truly subcubic query complexity this
seems quite
elusive okay so what about lower bounds
right so in the uh recent paper chakra
party Le C and one prove that for weekly
polinomial time algorithm there's a
evaluation Oracle lower bound of of n
linear
in so very recently in a joint work with
chakari grow and c word we could
slightly improve over this uh bound to n
log n for strongly polinomial time
algorithm but this lower bound currently
only works against deterministic
algorithm so again you see that there
are very significant caps between upper
and lower bounds for for all these
various settings and sort of trying to
get close this Gap or in particular
getting sub quadratic quer complexity
for weekly and strongly polom time
algorithm right now seems Out Of
Reach okay so given these barriers it is
sort of natural to ask what additional
structural assumptions do we need to
actually enable faster algorithms and
this talk we'll focus on what is called
sparse submodular function minimization
where we assume the minimizer of the
submodular function has at most K
elements okay it has more than one
minimizers we just assume that one of
them has at most K
element and we ask can we design faster
weakly and strongly polinomial time
algorithms when K is
small so why should we be interested in
sparsity well first of all this is sort
of a natural assumption that rises in
some
applications but kind of more
importantly at least for myself this
problem is sort of a test bad for new
algorithmic techniques which might help
us go beyond uh the current
state-of-the-art algorithms for
sfm okay so roughly what happens is that
the current uh techniques using the
state-of-the-art algorithms for sfm
cannot really leverage
sparsity but if you see some of the for
example the strongly polinomial type
algorithms SP sub instances turn out to
be one of the barriers for improving the
runtime for strongly polinomial time
algorithms I'll hopefully give you a bit
more insight into these later on but
before that I want to also say that
sparsity is also interesting in terms of
recent efforts in designing parallel
algorithms for
sfn so we will particularly be
interested in paralyzation in terms of
queries to the evaluation
Oracle so formally uh we consider this
query round model model where in every
round the algorithm can make up to poly
and parallel queries to the evaluation
Oracle get the answers and move to the
next round okay so the total number of
rounds needed by the algorithm to
actually find the minimizer as star one
of the minimizers as star is called the
parallel depth of the
algorithm and we hope to design
algorithms such for which the parallel
depth is much much smaller than the
number of actual querries
makes somewhat surprisingly the best
parallel algorithms for sfm are those
sequential ones so if you look at the
query complexity of these uh these
algorithms divide all of them by a
factor of n you will get the current
state-of-the art parallel depth I would
briefly explain where this n factor of n
come from but for now just believe me
okay so again you see this uh this
significant cap gets inherited from the
previous
one so what about par lower bounds in
the recent paper chaki Chen and can
proved that Weekly polinomial time
algorithms must make at least n to the
13 Rounds of queries to the evaluation
orle uh in the joint work chakra gr and
for we could prove that for strongly
polinomial time algorithms you need at
least roughly n
rounds so our our bound is actually
information theoretical so this matches
this upper bound uh for the exponential
time out algorithms this is one of the
very few settings where you could
actually get height upper and lower
bouts but for weekly polinomial time
algorithms and strongly polom time
algorithms there are still significant
polyn factor gaps between the upper and
lower
bounds somewhat interestingly sorry yes
I I missed something so the the lower
bound uh uh is on strongly is on
algorithms that are strongly
polinomial
the the bottom one is the the top one is
for weekly polinomial so okay you saying
that they were matching and I'm trying
to I'm trying to this one is actually
for for any algorithm making a poly n
number of queries so this is doesn't
really depend on the additional
computation yeah so it's actually
information theoretical like lower
bound any other
questions so it turns out that the
minimizers in these lower bound examples
are actually dense so sort of it's an
interesting question to ask does if we
assume sparsity can we actually go
beyond these lower bounds or or upper B
can we get a faster parallel algorithm
under sparsity
assumption okay so in our paper we give
sort of the first positive answers to
all these
questions so our first result is a
deterministic weekly polinomial time
algorithm which has polyk parallel
depth so this previous lower Bound by
chakari uh Chana directly implies that
there's a k Cube sorry K to the 13 lower
bound depth lower Bound for
here so sort of the polyk is the best
thing you could hope for except that our
poly polyk right now is a little big
it's something like K to the 6 seven but
when K is small this is uh this is
Su we also give a a randomize strongly
polom time algorithm with n polyk
query so you might ask can we okay why
do we have two theorems here weakly
strongly deterministic randomized
parallel query can we hope to get one
uniform theorem which achieves all these
things you know in the best in the best
tense okay that for some technical
reason currently we cannot achieve that
in the paper it's a great open problem
I'll mention that at the end okay for
the rest of the talk I will be focusing
on just on this first theorem okay where
our goal is to get a weekly polinomial
time algorithm with depth parallel depth
polinomial only in the sparse
Decay
okay so the way we kind of hope to do
this is to apply compx optimization so
as in all state-ofthe-art algorithms I
showed you in the table is to apply
Comax onization to this natural
extension for subm modular functions uh
to the unit hyp Cube this is called the
loasis tension and it satisfies very
nice properties for example for any
subset s the function value at s agrees
with the loasis tension at the
corresponding vertex indicator of s this
is the a vector where it is one for all
the element inside s and zero outside of
s okay this is what it means to be an
extension right and also the loox
intention has the same minimum value as
the submodular
function it kind of most importantly the
subgradient of the lovas extension uh
for submodular functions can be computed
very efficiently you can actually
compute them in one round and nend
queries and this factor of one round and
nend queries is exactly where the factor
of n between parallel depth and quer
complexity comes
from okay I'm not going to Define Lis
extension in the interest of of time but
these are the properties we we have for
them okay in terms of state-of-the-art
algorithms all apply cutting plane
methods to the loasis
tension this is for some good reason
because convergence rate of cutting
plane methods would depend
logarithmically on the on the range of
the function
M and this in fact already give you the
current best weekly polinomial time
algorithms for
sfn however there are some inherent
barriers inherent limitations of cutting
plane methods in particular they are
Dimension dependent meaning that they
take at least
iterations which uh each iteration you
need to compute a subgradient which
makes n queries so this is typically at
least n Square queries and both of these
the the the ner n iterations and n
Square queries are too much for us to
afford in The Spar
setting kind of more crucially cutting
plane methods don't seem to be able to
Leverage The sparcity
Assumption so then it's natural to ask
okay we have gradient information so
what about first order methods what
about gradient descent type of
algorithms okay these first order
methods are great in the sense that they
can leverage problem geometry better
than cutting plane methods for example
sparity however they come with their own
limitation in particular their
convergence rate are usually polinomial
inverse polinomial in the accuracy for
sfm the accuracy is stiic one/ M so this
means that you the number of iterations
would be polinomial in M the set of
first order methods is typically not
great in designing weakly and strongly
polinomial algorithms but rather a
different set of algorithms called
pseudo polinomial that I'm not not going
to Define
here okay so what should we do so it
turns out that very roughly we could get
around the limitation of first order
methods in the sparse setting by sort of
drawing inspiration from recent
framework on strongly polinomial time
algorithms which uses Duality let me
introduce a few what Duality means in
the context of sfm okay so the Dual
space of the loasis tension is what is
called the base polytope so given so
this is the set of all V dimensional
Vector Y which satisfy the following
constraints for any subset s y of s
meaning the sum of the coordinates of Y
inside s is at most F of
s and in particular for the entire set
so the sum of all the coordinates of Y
has to be equal to F of
Y so
these okay the base polytop satisfy a
lot of amazing combinatorial
properties which I unfortunately don't
have time to talk about but I'll give
you one sentence which sort of you know
justifies why this is a duality so
subgradients of the V tension are
exactly vertices of the base
polytop
okay so in a seminal work admon proved
the following Duality theorem for subm
modular function minimization in
particular the minimum value of the
loasis tension which we know is just the
minimum value of the subm modular
function Itself by definition okay so
let me write that as F star this is the
maximum over all the vectors y in the
base polytope of this quantity y minus V
okay so what is this
quantity y minus this Vector is the
coordinate wise minimum of the vector Y
and the zero Vector so Yus V this is the
sum of all the coordinates in y minus
this is just the sum of all the negative
coordinates in
y the theorem by admon also called min
max theorem says that the maximum of the
sum of the negative coordinates of any
Vector in the base polytope this is
exactly equal to the uh the minimum
value of the subm modular
function and not just that they have the
same value if you give me an optimal
dual solution fstar in the base polytope
you can actually read off some
coordinates that must be in the
minimizer so any coordinate I which is
negative in the Dual solution must be in
the
Mizer why this is the only proof I'm
going to give you in this talk this is a
on line proof so assume a coordinate the
I such that satisfies y star I smaller
than zero but not in the minimizer then
we have the following contradiction
let's read from right to left F of SAR
is at least Y star of SAR this because y
star is in the base polytope and we have
this
constraint I claim y star of s star the
sum of coordinates of Y star and S star
is bigger than the sum of all the
negative coordinates in
v why because we're missing out this
coordinate I which is negative and we
might have some positive coordinates
here but this only helps that equality
inequality
sorry okay and finally y star the sum of
the negative coordinates in y star is
exactly F star so you get the
contradiction so it means that if you
give me an optimal dual solution I would
be able to get information about the
Primal optimal solution the optimal
solution of the original submodular
function but of course from a
algorithmic perspective you would never
be able to compute this uh this thing
exactly what you could get compute from
applying compx optimization is an
approximate dual solution so you get
some Vector Y in B of f in base polytope
such that the sum of the negative
coordinates of y is at least fstar minus
Delta the right hand side is always
satisfied for any Vector y in the base
polytope so the non-trivial condition is
the left hand
side terms of you could get that's such
an approximate Primal approximate dual
solution you could again get some
information about what's in the
minimizer in particular any coordin i y
i such that is smaller than negative
Delta must be in the minimizer s
star okay but how small datta has to be
before we can find such a
coordinate in the previous work Le for
one and D they essentially proved that
Delta has to be smaller than roughly one
over n Cube one over polyan before you
can find okay before you can get some
minimizer
information right so this says that if
you run try to get this uh certificate
uh from Dual solution from first order
methods you need poly and iterations
which is which is crazy
large and this is par particular the
reason why they're running cutting plane
methods in their algorithm
okay but in The Spar setting as I'll
sort of try to show you later on you can
actually get minimizer information when
data is only one over polyk you can
prove
this however the requirement that you
get approximate dual solution is a
little too strict and you and it seems
first methods cannot is not strong
enough to compute this the polyk
iterations so what should we do sort of
central to our argument is this new no
called SP St certificate so instead of
controlling all the negative coordinates
of Y at the same time we only need that
the K most negative coordinates of Y to
be sandwiched between F star minus Delta
and F star you can prove this upper
bound always holds in The Spar setting
so again it's the lower bound is sort of
the central the non-trivial part the
non-trivial Assumption okay so why star
y minus K of V this is the sum of the K
most negative entries of of this Vector
y
Ms
okay right so let's first convince
ourselves that this is a much weaker
assump weaker condition so okay so even
if the K most negative coordinates is at
least fstar minus Delta you could have a
lot of other negative but very close
zero coordinates but there can be a lot
of them so you might not be have a
control over the sum of all the negative
coordinates but it turns out that this K
most negative coordinate is the correct
characterization of s star of f star in
The Spar setting in particular you can
prove the minim max theorem or Duality
theorem for this quantity in the sparse
case Okay so sort of the the the high
level overview of what we are what we
showed was
that even though this is a weaker
setting than approximate dual solution
when you compute this with Delta being
one over poly you can still get a
minimizer
information and more importantly now
first order methods are able to compute
these weaker Notions of dual
certificate okay I'll very quickly talk
about each one of these two
points okay so let's recall that suppose
we have a a sparse dual certificate with
Delta and
K we can always assume that the
minimizer is non positive by shifting
our function to have the empty set
evaluating at
zero and uh you can actually prove that
s four if you have a coordinate in the
sparse tool certificate with uh that is
negative than minus Delta then they must
be in the
minimizer okay so this means that if
Delta is smaller than fstar over poly K
that such a coordinate must
exist why because the K most negative
coordinates is roughly know F star when
Delta is really really small so one of
them has to be negative than F star over
K will be more negative than negative
Delta
but the question is can we actually
compute them like very efficiently well
you can hope to do this if F star is
very negative as we'll see in the second
part we can hope to do so if F star is
very negative but when F star is very
close to zero our accuracy would also be
very close to zero so there is no hope
in that case so how do we handle this
this
case okay it turns out that there's a
very there's a simple trick to get
around this issue by reducing to the
case when F star is very negative so if
F star is very close to zero we are
going to consider an element P with a
large marginal value F of P okay large
Singleton value F of P okay this is our
p and we consider this contracted
function FP on the set of uh no on the
elements outside of P okay so this
contracted function is defined as you
take a set that's not containing P FP of
s is defined as F of s Union P minus F
of
P
okay so now if p is in the
minimizer then this contractive function
would have a minimum value of f star
minus F of p f star is close to zero FP
is very big so this means that this
contracted function if P isn't the
minimizer and F of p is large the
contracted function would have a very
negative minimum value so you can
directly apply the previous uh the
argument on the previous slide to this
function and you will get information
about the minimizer in the following
sense if p is the minimizer then some
other element Q must also be in the
minimizer this is what called Arc
information in the literature U and
turns out this is enough this is good
enough and more importantly you can do
this in parallel for all the elements P
at the same time
right so this basically says it suffices
to just solve up to this accuracy fstar
over polyk accuracy when F star is is
negative okay so how do we do that okay
let's uh let's try to get a dual dual
certif P sorry Spar do certificate when
for Delta being smaller than F star or
poly K when F star is negative enough so
the idea is to apply first word method
on the cas Simplex which contains our
minimizer uh so of standard analysis of
miror descent says that the convergence
rate will depend on the L Infinity Norm
of the subgradients and the subgradients
are actually marginals of the subm
modular function you can actually show
which I'm going to sort of skip a lot of
details but you can actually show that
they are possibly bounded by F star when
F star is sufficiently negative sorry
absolute value of f star but they could
be very very
negative but there's a very natural very
simple fix to this is that you just
truncate all the negative subgradients
uh sorry negative coordinates of the
subgradient to roughly negative K times
F star okay and then this will make sure
that the number of iterations is poly K
of course by truncation you don't get
the true subgradients of the loasis
tension so you will not get something
exactly in the base polytope but you get
something sufficiently close that will
make the argument in part mod
work so sort of putting things together
when F star is negative enough you run
truncated miror dist stent and produce a
d a sparse dual certificate with Dela
being smaller than fstar or poly K using
only polyk iterations and then you can
find a coordinate in the minimizer okay
since there's a kpse minimizer this can
only happen at most poly K depth in
total in the other case you just
consider the contracted function and
reduce to the first
case okay I'm going to skip a little bit
of detail so I want to quickly sort of
mention what happens in this theorem to
so the parallel algorithm actually uses
n Square poly K query and this is
because we need to compute the
subradiance takes n queries for all the
contracted function f of P right this is
n * n so here are the ideas to sort of
overcome this query uh
issue so we are actually going to apply
a more refined local Norm analysis
tailored to subm modular structures to
prove a better convergence analysis and
then we are going to avoid Computing all
the entire subgradients by doing
sampling and somehow this will work and
and we'll kill one of the factors in
all right so just Briefly summarize so I
introduced the problem of sparse sfm as
a test bad for new sfm techniques um and
I sort of mentioned this cutting plane
versus first grade first order methods
dilemma in designing sfm algorithms
where cutting place has geometric
convergence which which is amazing but
is dimension dependent and doesn't
really leverage
sparsity first water methods on the
other hand is dimension free and better
leverage sparsity but it's convergence
rate is polinomial and it depends on the
size of the gradient
crucially okay but somehow we could
resolve this dilemma uh for the first
order methods using this notion called
Spar stol certificates okay and by using
TR The miror Descent we could get up to
one over poly accuracy in polyk
iterations and this will allow us to
infer minimize our
information right so I want to conclude
with a few open problems so for sparse
sfm current ly our polinomial dependence
on uh which I didn't really show you is
actually quite big so can we get a
smaller polinomial dependence hopefully
matching even the you know the the one
when when there is no sparse
solution okay and uh can we get the best
of both like all worlds result can we
get a deterministic polyk depth end
times polyk query strongly polinomial
time algorithm okay which would combine
like the two theorems I showed
you
and sort of the study of this sparse sfm
kind of give some in better insights in
the design of sfm algorithms and I think
it's like interesting to revisit some of
the open problems in designing fastar
algorithms for sfm can we draw some
inspiration from the sparse case Okay in
particular can we design a strongly
polinomial sfm algorithm with end to the
like with truly subcubic query
complexity or truly sub quadratic
parallel
depth can we design a weekly polinomial
time algorithm with sublinear uh
parallel
depth okay and what about Sub Sub sub
quadratic query complexities for weakly
and even strongly polom time algorithms
okay and that's it thank you for your
attention any
[Applause]
question scrolling back to the
definition of far dual certificate I had
a maybe silly question about it yeah
yeah sure so
so like basically my question is like
why why K minus is like smaller than YK
right y k uh K minus is bigger than YK
that then ah it's the sum of the K yeah
this is bigger than y minus a
v negative oh see see yeah yeah okay
cool yeah yeah yeah so so somehow like
but that's a good point related to that
question is like why is this always
bounded by fstar it turns out you can
still get that yes Al is bigger than
thanks Yus
B all right
so so so a separate problem of
minimizing a sub modular function
subject to a cardinality constraint of K
is really hard right and that's
completely different than it is it's a
completely different thing oh it's a
very different thing I I don't yeah oh
oh the the question is like minimizing
subm modular function subject to uh
cardinality constraint of K I think
that's a very very different question
and I'm not sure what's the if op is sp
yeah this is assuming there is a op
sparse which makes the problem like you
promise that there is a sparse a sparse
solution can you just site uh one
example application where that might be
the case oh for for
sparsity I for example I think in um
okay good question I think that I listed
something like I think there was a
paper many many years ago which says
that we try to model speech recognition
by by by some I mean this is not s
of-the-art application but there I think
they have some kind of sparsity uh
conditions any kind of maybe signal
processing I think so yeah yeah that's
the sort of type of application I was
one of the type of application I was
thinking for like also like for example
feature selection or something but I I
I'm not really yeah in the ml space to
to all right so let's thank you
[Applause]
than okay and uh we have